you
let's try the Sicilian now let's go with
the caro-kann you just got juked you
just got Jude alright
so French yeah French caro-kann advance
I was thinking French first like a
second there because there's an advanced
French but advanced a variation of the
Carol con my bad Bishop is outside of my
pawn chain
let's throw my Knights here and here and
then look for c5
back up or play night here if I back up
why would I want to do that to recapture
with my night to recapture with my pawn
let's back up if he takes my bishop I'm
gonna get the a file under the H file
that's why I'm backing up there that's
the plan
he's the expendable Bishop that's the
word I like to associate with this guy
right here the expendable bishop I'm
okay if a knight gets my light square
Bishop it's my dark square Bishop who's
really more valuable so c5 okay
c5 I could play let's do it
I need to make sure I could meet night
here with Knight here and cover d6 this
is very important as otherwise ninety
six absolutely kills me after pawn takes
I have this move knight c6 where I'm
hitting c5 twice and E 5 twice and you
can only defend one so this is a this is
the way to go got a play Knight here
just in the nick of time my bishop needs
to be here to defend he's there to
defend and it's a free night or is he
does he come out with the cost he does
come with the cost
yes he does I wonder if my opponent even
saw that moved c3 very quickly so Queen
takes Knight Knight check King here and
maybe King here and then King here maybe
my king could hunt that night write down
the other considerations to play first
pawn here but you can be sure that after
this we'll have first Knight takes
bishop pawn takes and then the knight
will run away here or drop into d6 so
let's let's stay focused here
let's let's go with what let's go with
pawn takes might be interesting to pawn
takes pawn takes maybe I could get this
check in first and then take the knight
so that after Knight takes I could play
King seven and after Knight takes rook I
could recapture with the rook
so after pawn takes pawn if pawn takes I
could give this check and then take the
night and meet knight check with King II
seven however after pawn takes pawn
Knight takes bishop pawn takes Bishop
Knight takes rook pawn takes pawn it's
very interesting but is it necessary do
I really need to complicate matters or
is there a cleaner approach where I
could play without risk I'm gonna go
with this approach cuz I'm scared I like
to play now not because I'm scared well
yeah actually because I am scared but
maybe better stated because I like to
play positions where I have all the play
and there's very little risk of losing
or where positions where I'm trying to
play for two results right either a
winner or drop where my opponent is the
one who's on their heels so apparently
the night is my opponents considering d6
or a3
if d6 I think I could take it and then
and then win this pawn back without too
much issue well I'm definitely gonna
take it so okay well we didn't have that
is there is there any reason to maintain
this tension does my pawn really have
some idea of pushing here I don't
believe so
so let's resolve that tension right away
he's misplaced he's boxed out due to my
deep on and
upon control of these two so he's the
worst placed minor piece for white I'm
gonna try to play off of that I have
this file there might one day be some
Queen h4 move threatening made on h2 and
something lateral so this pawn is
dropping now pawn takes was needed I'm
pretty sure in order to defend this
square and of these two knights I'm
gonna take with the one that's furthest
back the one who's less active and I'll
saw I'm in a position if I need to take
out the bishop I could still be taking
out the bishop so I'm up upon in this
position and time wise material wise I'm
up the other two main factors just the
general considerations are what there's
the material there's time and there's
space space I guess you could say I have
a slight space advantage but time wise
is the other thing that may be the more
important thing that I'm looking into
and I don't know that either of us
really have an advantage in that in that
area so just take the bishop
yeah let's just take the bishop let's
see how let's see how white recaptures
if you take with the pawn I could throw
in this check and then white I'll have
to go on castle taking with the Queen
it's my night but I had planned really
just to come back here to a classic
square counters hacking move and I think
that this is good I did consider also
Bishop d6 but I didn't like this idea of
playing f4 and then when my knight moves
I'd be dropping g7 so just a counter
tacking move Bishop here Queen hear
something focusing on this h2 square
this rook is active Queen here's my
first thought I don't know that she has
really a better Square maybe maybe she
does let me get my Bishop developed and
maybe I could take the knight not needed
really under a minute Bishop d6 can't
castle I'm on h2 you know this is gonna
be game over this is this is leading to
mate very soon that's Bishop here
let's check I'm doing this so that
there's eventually not a Queen move
right here yeah that was just missed
eight that h2 squared the bill gates
square right that's the bill maybe
that's the bill gates square from now on
right the bill gates square 2 million
people know what I'm talking about
all right good game Jan PI how this
would have followed is there's some
blocks you could be throwing in but
after a king here there's the forest
made of rook check King takes Queen h4
to h2 so let's back up something went
wrong let's flip the board here
caro-kann advance this is awkward this
is I didn't say during the game but
Knight c3 is not a good square for the
knight
you want to have this pond free to move
to reinforce your base point d4 this is
important if you're not able to maintain
your pawn on d4 that means your ePHI v5
pond becomes that much more difficult to
defend and as it turned out in the game
you ended up dropping the pond now there
was granted there was a way that you
could have been preventing me from
capturing on e5 but nevertheless you
shouldn't be obstructing your C pond he
wants to be able to move to reinforce
your base point d4 so what might be a
better move is Bishop to e2 maybe I
could go one step further actually
because I was talking about reinforcing
your d5 your d4 pawn with c3 but there
are also some lines where this pawn
wants to play to c4 and the position B
can open up very quickly just running
with this right here if you play Bishop
e2 this is a common move 97 after
castles another common move is Knight d7
basically telling your Knights right in
front of your king and queen and
eventually on the black side I'd look to
play c5 so again running with Bishop e2
97 Castle Knight d7 a move you could
then be going with is Knight d2 staying
out of the way the pun and then you're
in a position to me c5 with c3 or if you
want to be a little bit more aggressive
you can place c4 and really blow up the
position and try to take advantage of
the fact that it's gonna take me still a
little bit before I can be castled right
if my Knights on e7 it still would take
me a knight move a bishop move and well
the castling will would take three moves
before I'm castled so in short this is
something and by the way this is the
short variation is it not after a Nigel
short he plays this Knight f3 Bishop e2
castles but the quick summary here
you could be going forward with Bishop
e2 I get my Knights to these two yet
castled and when c5 is played you could
play c3 or c4 definitely don't obstruct
your seat pond you went after my
LightSquared Bishop you'd look to get
into the d6 square and I think best is
to just simply not even give me the
option of maybe capturing the night so
just take my bishop right now I'm
thinking that that was just missed
during the game I could be wrong with
how quickly c3 was played because there
was still some calculation needed with
this fork and knowing if I could get the
two minor pieces for the rook and
there's things of that nature but
probably just take the bishop
immediately I gave your knight a kick
and maybe you could actually get away
with this Knight check pawn Knight check
Bishop takes pawn here if Queen b8 or
some knight move to try and hit the pawn
you do have bishop here maybe you could
be making me struggle to track down that
past d6 pawn I I don't know as a turnout
in this game at this point you need to
take with the pawn to keep a5 and as
soon as that drops the game is pretty
much it's a very important pond III know
it's just a pond but it's it's a central
pond and things are a lot more free your
Knights struggling and theirs without
the pawn on e5 h2 is more accessible
that's just an additional benefit but in
short you're just you're dropping a pawn
here so pawn takes is pretty much needed
if Bishop check as a response you could
block with the bishop there's no time to
take here just yet because the bishop on
b4 would be unprotected so pawn takes
Bishop check Bishop d2 I guess it's
still uncomfortable for you after Queen
a5 but it's it's really getting all the
way back to I believe this earliest
point with the Knights deployment not
obstructing your C pawn there
important to take into account the the
structure the structural changes what
what pond pushes I'm going to want to
make I'm going to want to strike at your
your base point have your pond free to
reinforce that and it's a tough road
ahead at that point all righty
good game let's close out of this
you